well it's going full Pelt now there's an
awful lot more boats this morning than
we saw at all yesterday yesterday it was
just civilians using their own boats and
anything that could get wading through
the water to get to their pets to get to
their homes to try and get to their
elderly relatives many of whom have
stayed behind despite all the the
bombing and shelling they've all
disappeared now but just give you an
idea of how much it's come up overnight
we were able to walk down this road
yesterday we walked down those streets
and it was more flooded further down you
can see the signposts probably in the
distance that was walking level now it's
if we I'd say overnight we've just been
trying to do a rough reckoner ourselves
we reckon it probably come up about four
foot overnight so substantially more
flooded which I guess is why the police
and the military are out here in some
numbers and they're bringing boats now
whether that's enough boats we don't
know certainly there's going to be I
think growing anger about what's
happened and also a sense of desperation
because a lot of this water it looks
very tranquil but it's absolutely even
yesterday we were wading through
sewage basically and this is right in
the in the in the Town Center they're
worried about the future implications of
disease we were speaking to a lot of the
volunteers who've come here to help and
they are bringing you know piles of
medicine antibiotics cleaning materials
and this they expect to carry on and
possibly keep on Rising maybe for the
next four or five days before it's like
they hope it's like slightly starts to
recede and disappear but overnight the
various Dam construction experts have
been trying to work out how much more of
the foundations are likely to
disintegrate around the dam and they're
predicting it will because of the sheer
force of the water it's been holding
back and that will unleash even even
more water